let's bring in chad wolfe he was
basically called out just now former
acting dhs secretary
heritage foundation visiting fellow chad
you guys broke it they had to rebuild it
from the bottom up it just takes time
things are dramatically better
do you have a response
well brian thanks for having me on and
i'll just say the facts don't support
that ludicrous
claim obviously we handed them a secure
border and the numbers
from illegal apprehensions and numbers
across the board demonstrate that the
border was safe it was secure
and the immigration system was working
what the bite administration would want
you to believe
is that they inherited a broken system
but now they are going back to the
system
under the obama administration where
catch and release is prevalent
they're allowing individuals to come
into the united states even though they
don't
qualify for asylum and then they are
blocking ice
law enforcement officials ability to
remove these individuals so
in fact the bite administration is again
going back and they are reinstituting a
broken immigration
system and they're trying to put that
back into place and it's the wrong
approach and i don't believe that the
american people support that
you know what the mexican president
doesn't believe that either he said
expectations were created with the
government of president biden
there would be a better treatment of
migrants and that has caused central
american migrants and also from other
countries wanting to cross the border
thinking it's easier to do so what you
guys did is link trade first time since
the 1980s
with migration you told mexico
escalating tariffs unless you crack down
and then you had mutual respect for each
other and you began to crack down and
things
slowed down that has been dramatically
reversed
and that's what we're witnessing now and
if you could tell me about a system
that actually allowed 1600
illegals to come through the yuma
section and 2200 to come from rio grande
valley
please tell me how over the weekend
please tell me how that is better
to me it is not better they're just
building additional housing for these
illegals
who believe school's out
well absolutely and in the men and women
on the border the men and women of
border patrol
see this and when they see their
leadership at the department
or leadership from the white house say
the border is closed and the border is
secure and then the numbers brian you
just
indicated they know that's a lie they
know that's not what's happening on the
ground and it's because of the policies
that have been put in place
so it doesn't matter what type of
messaging that the bite administration
wants to say to the american people the
facts on the ground
matter and they're telling the the truth
and that is that border
continues to be open because of the
policies that been put in place but
you're exactly right
we worked with mexico and the northern
triangle to sign
over a dozen different agreements to
address that security that prosperity
uh issue right and real quick the kids
are
in houston in particular teachers are
overwhelmed because these illegals are
coming in
english is a second language if that and
now they're overcrowded all these
classrooms
you know these chamber events are
happening across the country now right
well absolutely and again you know as we
say uh you know
border border towns are not just along
the border they're everywhere and
they're across
america so as these kids and as these
families come into the u.s
they don't just stay along the border
they go into major metropolitan areas
and you're putting strain
on american schools across the country
and that's something that we certainly
need to be concerned about
chad thanks so much you got to keep
fighting back because they keep on
calling you guys out and you're not
there to defend yourselves
so we want to give you that opportunity
thank you